this patch of land about 70 miles
outside of Houston Texas doesn't look
like much but if you zoom in these
little rectangles sit above a powerful
economic and political tool just
underground is a network of caverns full
of oil part of the US's strategic
petroleum Reserve or spr since March
President Biden has been tapping into it
in a big way the department of energy
released another 15 million barrels from
the Strategic petroleum Reserve
altogether the administration will have
released 180 million Barrels in 2022 the
largest drawdown from the spr ever
pumping from the reserve the
administration says has helped lower
Americans energy bills and stabilize
markets but some oil industry experts
disagree when we talk about the forces
that are hitting the oil Market this
does very little to change the tide
here's how the Strategic petroleum
Reserve can be used to try to bring down
prices and why some are skeptical that
Biden's moves are working
along the Texas and Louisiana coasts the
caverns are located in Bryan Mound big
hill West Hackberry and Bayou Choctaw as
of October 28th the reserve held about
399 million barrels of oil you know
we're talking about some four storage
sites 60 Caverns the largest one I think
is big enough that you could fit the
Willis Tower that you have in Chicago in
it and the tower for reference is 1451
feet so that's uh that's substantial you
can put a lot of oil in there so why
does the US government keep this much
oil on hand it goes back to the energy
policy and conservation Act of 1975.
during the 1973-74 OPEC oil embargo
prices for oil skyrocketed as a result
we Face the possibility of temporary
fuel shortages and some increases in
fuel prices in America this led to
gasoline shortages across the country
okay
no gas today when President Ford signed
the ACT into law it was an attempt to
establish a buffer against future Supply
shocks of this kind it specified that
presidents can tap into the reserves
when there's an energy Supply
interruption or due to obligations of
the United States under the
International Energy program over the
years that's meant a few things
historically the U.S has drawn into the
spr for emergency and Non-Emergency
realizes what's an emergency release
it's a hurricane that disrupts oil
production that wasn't on emergency drug
it's a cell mandated by Congress as part
of policy making using that Authority
Biden tapped into the reserves starting
in the spring and through this fall
we're going to continue to stabilize
markets and decrease the prices at a
time when the actions of other countries
have caused such volatility the market
for oil has been very tight and the U.S
has had to balance
the fight against inflation and gasoline
prices has been a main driver of that
with targeting Russia and punishing it
for its uh invasion of Ukraine releases
from the spr can help calm oil Traders
by injecting more crude supplies into
Global markets
right now oil supplies are tight causing
high prices
by taking oil from the reserves and
selling it to Traders and refiners Biden
is increasing Supply in an effort to
lower prices at the pump because
gasoline prices are largely determined
by oil prices this strategy has worked
in the past take when the government
tapped into the reserve after Hurricane
Katrina as an example the U.S sold 11
million barrels to keep production
steady for the rest of the country after
the release price is stabilized and
something similar happened earlier this
year due to Biden's March announcement
when he said he'd release 1 million
barrels a day Treasury Department
estimates that the releases that we've
seen this year lower the price of
gasoline between 13 and 31 cents per
gallon so that's a pretty broad range
but industry critics say that the oil
releases have artificially lowered
prices in the short term dissuading
investment in new oil production U.S
officials said they had intended the
reserve releases to be a stop Gap until
domestic production ramped up there's
only been a slight slight increase in
production so far this year about six
percent since since January and that's
largely because the um the large
producers in the US have been
conservative with their spending Biden
has tried to deal with lower production
by announcing that he would refill the
reserve that means oil companies can
invest to wrap up production now with
confidence they'll be able to sell their
oil to us at that price in the future
seventy dollars but analysts have said
that shifting from releasing the
reserves to refilling them could remove
large amounts of oil from the global
market which would continue to tighten
supplies and contribute to inflation
they say that Biden should wait to
refill the reserves until there's a
surplus of oil and lower prices the
latest release from the reserve the 15
million barrels are set to be delivered
in December my dentist said that it
would ask his team at the department of
energy to
depending on the situation make further
releases from the spr so it has not real
ruled out additional releases and
ERS refilled
filled oh but Biden says there is still
enough in case of emergency